(audience cheering)
- Hi!
- [Kelly] I would wear that!
- I would wear that I would wear this
- I feel like I should
be on a beach somewhere.
If we would like to just leave now and go.
- I would follow you
to that beach. (laughs)
- So have y'all met before?
- [Natasha] No.
- I don't know if y'all ever met before
- No, but I admire your work.
- Likewise
- We devoured "White
Lotus". You were wonderful.
- Oh my goodness.
Thank you so much.
I'm obsessed.
This is wild.
- This is a wild thing.
(audience applauds)
Wait, I love finding
out that you're musical.
So did you do musical theater growing up?
Did you?
- I did barely in high school.
I'm what you call
a karaoke person versus
someone who's just like,
Oh yeah, I sing professionally.
Cause it's terrifying.
- But when you get terrified..
- I get terrified because I feel like..
- That's how I get acting.
- What?
- Exactly, I could sing in front
of billions of people and
be like, (makes funny sound)
- [Natasha] Yeah
- (audience and Ted laugh)
- But if I have to act,
I want to full on..
my pants.
- Yes yes, yes, yes, yes,
yes, no, no, no, no, no.
Clean up on aisle me!
- [Kelly] Clean up on aisle me.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Yeah. I get so nervous and
that's why I don't do it.
Cause I don't enjoy it.
- I just love the acting so
much when I was in high school.
And so I wanted to be in everything.
So it's just like the
musical everything. (laughs)
But I auditioned for Music
Man, when I was a junior.
[Kelly] Yeah.
- And my best friend at the
time was hearing impaired
and I wanted to understand
her world better.
So I taught myself ASL.
And so I was like..
- That's cool.
- I will sign the song that
I sing for this audition.
Cause at least it'll distract me from the
the pressure of singing.
- That's beautiful!
- It, it was in theory, so..
- Oh
(audience laughs)
- What happened was during
the audition, I got nervous
as I predicted
and forgot the sign and, but my hands were
in the air and I committed by
just doing interpretive dance.
(audience laughs)
(Kelly laughs)
- [Natasha] Yeah.
- That's amazing.
- So I just kind of danced
along to what I was singing.
- You just moved your..
- Yeah and what, what put it
over the edge was the
crying that happened.
- Oh no
- As I was dancing with my answers
- Because you were like (Kelly
sings) "I'm going down".
- Yes
- Yes. It was, it was rough stuff
but I made the musical guys.
(audience cheers)
(Kelly laughs)
- I made the musical
- [Natasha] That's right. That's
right. I was in the chorus.
I was in the deep chorus.
I, they don't create
deep choruses nowadays
but my teacher created one for me.
- [Kelly] That's amazing.
Wait, have you ever had that moment
on stage where you just,
it didn't go as planned?
- Constantly!
- [Kelly] Yeah. Okay.
- I'm a 50\50 actor at best.
- [Kelly] Oh my God! (laughs)
- Oh
- I had a moment like that in high school.
I had one in high school and it was like
everyone was so loud and everyone was like
oh she can hit whistle notes.
So I was like, put a
whistle note in the song.
I was like, okay, cool.
But they started yelling so loud
that I couldn't hear the song.
- [Natasha] I know.
- So I did hit a note just
in a key for another song.
- Oh
(audience and Natasha laugh)
- And I
- fled
- [Natasha] Oh.
- Like to the back.. the
closest closet I could find
and just was like, you
know, you're in high school.
You're like, "It's over!"
- Your life ends when you mess up.
- Yeah. It was so big.
[Kelly] Now it's just funny.
- Yes. Now I can laugh about it.
- Now I'm just like, What?
(Kelly squeaks loudly)
(laughter)
(Kelly and Natasha make
loud squeaking noises)
- When you audition for
something, just be yourself.
[Kelly] Yeah.
- Don't try to do too much.
I did not know that better.
- It's kinda very thoughtful though.
That you had a friend that's really cool.
- Yes. Sarah Depner she's out there still.
Yeah.
- Ah, still waiting for that performance.
- I know!
(everyone laughs)
- I'm still working on
it. Still working on it.
- We will do this for you, Sarah.